what's the pollination welcome to
another league to 2019 video we are now
announcing new prizes a prize for this
week for the tour is a one-on-one
session actually let's hold off it's
gonna be a one-on-one session with Dan
Locke so if you guys don't know de Locke
he has a YouTube channel off the same
Dan mock the king of high ticket sales
he just crossed a million subscribers on
YouTube pumping out insane content we
are gonna be giving away for someone who
buys a ticket to the tour a chance to
meet Dan one-on-one we have to figure
out how to give up the spices yeah well
it's gonna be well there's some prizes
that occurred for the whole tour and
then for each city in the for each
ticket and this is a full-time job to
know this stuff then chances are you
guys that you okay let's track this all
up great so we're giving away prizes on
this tour I am doing a 90 day III city
tour I'm coming to a bunch of cities in
the u.s. to to move you from over
thinking from getting out of your head
and into action from doubling yourself
to believe in yourself more and I'm
coming to to teach you how to schedule
for success have it how to stop care
what other people think about you and
how to start taking action and it's
gonna be me educating at the front but
then also you guys doing work like you
are doing work you are taking action in
the event it's not just comin listen to
me and get motivated for three hours
it's three hours it's not just come and
listen to me get motivated for three
hours
it's we're gonna take action like that
thing you've been sitting on to the past
three months or 12 months or three years
we're building momentum I'm gonna apply
pressure so that you actually start
building your business doing the thing
that you're capable of doing and then
this can also be Q&A so like bring your
most
important questions this has to count
like this event these three hours this
one night is not just another night it's
not just going out to the movies like
this this event has to matter for you it
has to mean something to you otherwise
I've wasted my time and that pisses me
off so that's not gonna happen it's
gonna mean something so that's the
structure of each night Kelly we're
gonna do some you listen to me we do
some activities together you're gonna
take action you're gonna be doing work
and then and then Q&A bring your most
important questions it's an intimate
affair with me and you and some other
local entrepreneurs so that's that's
what we're doing
23 cities in the description and there's
a link you can go check it out for the
different cities we're giving away
prizes there's two prizes but giving
over a hundred thousand dollars worth of
prizes for people who are coming on the
tour they're divided into three
categories category number one is
everybody who gets a ticket gets a prize
we've already announced that everyone
who gets a ticket gets a one-on-one
coaching session with coach Lalit it's a
part of my team what did they use don't
do well with liddie we can they use it
dream I would say after after your event
just after April but after their event
six burgers coming up so after you come
then cuz you're gonna learn a lot in our
event and I think you get a better you
solutely sign as follow-up after so you
get a free session with Coach Lilly some
hundred dollar value you get it free for
buying your $25 ticket yes I should give
that email that you will reach out after
the event you have Lilly's email you
have your ticket you reach out and say I
want my support concession we're gonna
do it I'll give it to them in the event
yeah
plus you get my flex TX calendar which
is helping you schedule the most
important habit that you want to keep
for 2019 this is the the calendar I use
to make sure that I follow through in
the house and I'm trying to build and do
gonna get a pdf version of that
everybody buys a ticket period then we
have the
prizes per city for the city I'm going
to be meeting three people out of coffee
shop private you me and two other people
and me yeah I'm going to dig deeper all
so we're not going to go there me and
Nina and and you and two other people so
we're gonna pull one person at random
from the city yeah and then the other
two people is to reward the people
who've come from far away out of state
yeah the furthest you've come so there
to reward all the people who are gonna
put their goals ahead of their
convenience and travel by car by bus by
plane by train to get to a different
City whoever's come the furthest away
gets to meet me at the coffee shop two
days later for two hours so one person
at random in the audience and then the
two people who came the furthest away
get the private one on three with Nina
as well that's a huge bonus one on three
with me a tune
two days later it's got a shot okay okay
this is clear now right okay great
then we have I'm excited this is this is
exciting
then we have before the entire city just
gone excitement mister what was that
then we meet then we have the one per
entire tour Grand Prizes one person who
buys a ticket will be picked at random
to come and get some of these prizes so
the first one is six months of coaching
with me yeah six months of one-on-one
where once a month we're gonna get on a
call I'm here to help you through
building your business and get it to the
next step after it starts after the
works after the tour's finished yeah
it's because we have to pick one person
from the entire tour and then we'll see
for the next six months
yeah anyway so there's that then one
ticket to my workshop in May
to make money as a thought leader it's a
2000 dollar value it's spending three
full days morning to late evening with
me and my team helping you make money
from your ideas helping you learn how to
do what I do but for your industry so
make it on YouTube social media book
deals brand deals speaking gigs all that
kind of stuff
learn to make money from ideas to be a
thought leader $2,000 ticket somebody's
gonna get that then what we announced
last week was a one-on-one session
coaching session with you and Grant
Cardone a one-on-one coaching session
with you and Tom bill you found of
impact theory and part of quest
nutrition bill II know a company and now
announcing today a one-on-one session
with you and Dane lock so that's five
grand prizes all of those are like these
guys don't do consulting Riley I don't I
don't have a coaching program and Gregg
and Tom and Dan don't have consulting
packages so this is a special
opportunity for me yeah special they
don't do this even for their own stuff
most of the time so it's a good chance
to meet them and and if you around
successful people and you get a chance
to ask a question what question we do is
right how do you I can one person get to
know
Sonu one person get one price yeah so
this there's five grand prizes so far
they'll go to five different people can
they pick what they want or you pick
what ticket will pick will fly pick yeah
we're gonna like pick it pick random
pick random pick right so you got a
chance to whip those hundred
thousand-plus in rank in prizes solar
prizes and more more announcements
coming soon but today is a bad luck
announcement and I'm pretty excited I'm
pretty excited
what for when t suffices it's a $45
ticket right it's crazy
anyway
six month with Evan
I still value insane value plus the
actual events right like we're focused
on the prizes but the actual brain is
gonna be insane yeah
anyway okay it's life-changing
life-changing great
this is Nina's full-time job organizing
the tour what's our update what do you
want to talk about are you been doing
since last week and since last week last
we talked about we have to event read
the the location yeah so now those six
venues are posted so we have a venue for
Memphis Cincinnati Louis I think Tulsa
and other could give some love to the
Albuquerque okay okay so we're like a
third of the way through actually having
locations yeah yeah okay so next we
should have more but look you're not
picking the locations okay what else and
then I've been working on emails working
on sending those campaign email oh my
god those emails have to tell you to be
very detail-oriented every Melanie said
no I had to read through send it to
myself you time submission it's okay
they're not they said of that but that's
lame if anybody's getting like messed up
emails don't usually let me know new
zoom you're done which is we're gonna
email us you're gonna reaching out to
organizations local cities yeah not to
quite a few organization in Pittsburgh
so yeah if you guys have any local
entrepreneur clubs or groups or
organizations that you think might be a
fit for the local for your local city
yeah let me know email me at or Evan
Carmichael calm yeah I've been giving
some good thought to how I want to run
the event the content okay how to make
the most of it so I mean I can just get
up on stage and talk for three hours but
that's not that's not the point like
your how do I get the most out of you
guys so that you are actually taking
action
you know that's the fun things planned
but I'm still tinkering the funding that
bit so great okay let's get to some of
your comments from last week if you guys
want us to answer a question in next
week's video put it in the comments of
this video let's see what we got
millionaire by 21 grains and Tom are
awesome fire I love it it's gonna be
pretty epic to spend the one-on-one time
with them and see a great business ideas
Inc this is apply to people outside the
US yeah if you come out of the state you
can grand prize oh yeah well you may get
the grand prize but you'll likely get
the coffee shop beat up yeah right the
two people who come the farthest away
get the coffee shop neither small sign
of you and yeah yeah it's fine if you
come from outside the US you likely to
get the coffee shop Meetup so you get
the two-hour session with me and then
you get the chance to get all the
definitely prices per ticket but then
also the chance to get the grand prize
Mike travels Michael Tuohy like a rock
star called Michael oh yeah Michael
because it's Carmichael yeah I think
Paul Michael lot okay school rocks
artists Evan I'm planning to meet you
guys in st. Louis on Jamie 26 goals over
convenience I love it and I'm going to
India February first school of rock
stars is in techno Texas does she Texas
Texas yeah from Texas to st. Louis we
will see you January 26 filler rock
stars get the Instagram ready we'll do
some stories dr. Stan very gentle you
have been there all great prizes I love
a doctor stand come on out I think he's
based in is exactly in the warm I think
he's in Georgia pretty tres in Georgia
so come on out join skull rock stars in
st. Louis Rebecca I'm guessing this
doesn't count for people in South Africa
right if you come to the tour yeah right
take a spot you will win the copy shop
meet up pretty much for sure a letter I
want like this supportive partner with
me very lucky supporter fire me
what do you think are you support
pregnant what do you think well advise
you to give to somebody
who is working with their spouse
understand why are you doing this okay
and then you support yeah yeah we love
you it's awesome having somebody support
always I was having a facebook chat
today with somebody who's trying to
build and grow his business and who say
people working with a friend and he's
like I know if I wanted miksa to is is a
really close friend and like I love I
think it's the best because you never
dealt their loyalty you know and they
really care
it's just communicating over coming over
communicating over me kid you know like
if if Nina just absolutely sucked at
everything that she was doing for me we
wouldn't communicate and we move her on
to something else or if she'd go back
and get a job right by that it's just to
the conversations but when you have
people who love what like they love the
mission they really want to support you
i I've worked with lots of friends I've
worked with family I think it's I think
it's the best people people suck at it
because they don't communicate well
enough Kristen why is trying not on the
list but no when has happened in Toronto
so we updated that initial thinking of
having an event in Toronto but but it's
Hayden's last day and so I'm gonna spend
it with him instead of doing the Toronto
Debbie a happy husband a happy home
oh that's last week I think we asked
like having a wife happy life yeah happy
husband is what like give me something
happy husband so happy has been a happy
home home was where the heart is I think
that's true that's good happy husband
happy home
there are ages but this isn't run this
is there are all ages okay happy husband
happy home it's the four inches the rule
of life you have a happy husband you're
happy well what do you think okay I like
that
we love you Nina you getting love from
Debbie please make a video at hand
Henrik Lundqvist look at the description
in any video there's a link to request
line put it there
Ibis toolbar Ibis ibis pronounced said
okay I'll be waiting for you guys here
in Salt Lake sound like City Utah yeah
you know what that was interesting Salt
Lake because on the banner it said Salt
Lake but then I change it to salty
city I feel like we're supposed to put
the city on we gotta respect our Salt
Lake City friends just like we need to
know how to say Albuquerque there you go
what did you say before I think great
stuff that mean I love it having so much
fun thank you for the love happy husband
gets the lowing Wow holy Chihuahua
happy husband gets the loving can you
reading that happy husband gets the
loving nice
tarus Nita seems like a total sweetheart
Wow Lina's getting lots of love in the
comments what do you think are you told
us we hurry yeah of course yeah Wow I
don't even doubt that Lina it's just
total sweetheart a great chef idea grant
and Tom are awesome superb great if it's
over again you know you're so cute happy
face are you cute as well strict aah aah
Elliott Oh 7112 Denver double its Mitch
Moines who will see you in Colorado
looking forward to it tarz happy wife
happy life but a happy man is a man with
a plan but teamwork makes the dream work
and ours is just spin spin fire here in
the comments I like it
Prairie dodgers all caps holy moly
Minneapolis here I come I will figure it
out somehow hope your day is going good
I love it we will see you in Minneapolis
that's near the end right Minnesota
we're hitting at the end almost at the
end yeah it's almost at the end it's
like before Chicago yeah thanks like our
third or fourth last stop and we will
see you in Minneapolis we've never been
it I know I've been to Minnesota you've
never been done Minnesota's nice it's
totally rather than grains in time we're
gonna do that with the coaching
man I'd love to win that prize do we say
that if you buy multiple tickets you get
what you do right yeah just like if you
buy the three ticket package it's
cheaper three is 97 one is 45 2 is 75 I
think right so you can get 93 95 not 97
95 you know you get three chances to
to meet Tom or grant or day in right now
and then last one let's kill innocent
Abhishek is any YouTube viewer belonging
to other countries eligible for the
grand prize so it's not viewers you got
to get a ticket to the tour you gotta
come get a ticket show up at one of the
stops and if you're again from another
country we're gonna do the two one
the three on one Plus Nina's a little
selfish not me but two days later cool
those are announcements for now very
excited to meet you guys a lot of
progress happening in Pittsburgh is
coming soon Pittsburgh Columbus
Cincinnati what's the fourth one
no Indianapolis IN that's it this your
apologize he'll be in Indianapolis what
did you call it the first time no what
did you say
Indiana policy India Indianapolis or
something because I said freedom it's
the best we love Wow alright thank you
guys for watching to get your ticket to
the tour click on the link right next to
us we will see you there
continue to believe and we'll see you
there